[Music]
in these jobs time is of the essence but
with so many staff isolating
they're becoming much much harder to do
more critical staff will now be allowed
to test rather than isolate to keep key
services running
but industry bosses aren't convinced
we're all completely confused now about
what this government is proposing
and nobody seems to know what we're
going to be faced with on monday morning
and many questions remain unanswered
which jobs are exempt where and when
will testing centres be rolled out
for the rail industry the scheme isn't
the answer they should not bring forward
august 16th they said that that was
based on the science when they would
would have a peak and that maybe the
peak had passed
what we needed to do is bring back some
proper measures we need
uh compulsory face masks in public
transport and shops and other
locations when people are moving around
we need to bring back social distancing
and we need to bring back the other
measures which were controlling the
enviro
the virus and medical experts say it
could put
other staff at risk in this pandemic
for last 16 months the social care and
the health care worker
we have lost more than 1500 and
we can't afford to lose more in my view
by following these untested policies
i think what we got to do now is to have
real pilots
to see whether this particular policy by
department of health and boris johnson
is safe
sajid javid the health secretary who
today tested negative for covid19 said
risk assessments will protect staff
working with those on the testing scheme
daily contact testing of workers in
these critical sectors will help to
minimise any disruption caused by rising
cases in the coming weeks while ensuring
staff
are not put at risk but the only real
answer is vaccination and big names
including gareth southgate are stepping
up to combat hesitancy
for your younger ones especially the
chance for everything to open up to get
your freedom back
so much to that is going to rest on you
having the vaccine so
don't put it off any longer go and get
it done
in the months to come testing and
vaccination will work hand in hand to
protect us all from covid but
both rely on people coming forward as
these images from a testing center in
stockton today show
take-up in some areas still isn't as
high as it could be
kate mccann sky news